hello everyone and welcome to round
seven of this year's katar Masters we
have a very nice game between Magnus
Carlson and the murle kin we've had mly
a couple of times on the channel already
if you guys remember in 2019 he played a
game that I named I believe the greatest
Queen sacrifice of 2019 uh so if you
haven't seen it do check it out really
is quite wonderful it um reminiscent of
the old Queen captures on F6 by by the
great Rashid NM medov uh if you haven't
seen it first link in the description
below uh do check it out but now this is
a completely different type of game uh
and uh well also a very strong opponent
in that game I believe he faced ala uh
here he faces Magnus so let's check it
out we have Ponto E4 by Magnus Ponto E5
Knight to F3 Knight to C6 and Bishop to
B5 Magnus goes for theu Lopez we have
Pawn to A6 the mor morphy's defense
Bishop to A4 uh and Knight to F6 with
have Knight to C3 Pawn to B5 and B B3
and we have Bishop to
C5 uh the so-called uh I don't know if
if it's uh the arhangel variation I
think it is as Fabiano corana mentioned
it on his Twitter feed after the game
but I I think the original AR hangus is
without the Knight on C3 and with Bishop
on B7 uh I could be wrong though uh I I
will have to check but yeah here are
some standard moves are Pawn to D3
castles but here we have Knight to D5 by
Magnus only a few games in the database
with this move uh and now uh how do you
how do you play this well uh Pawn to D6
uh and uh you could also go instead of
this you could also go for Knight
captures on E5 it's uh perfectly
playable Knight captures Pawn to D4
attacks the bishop and Knight here and
once you capture Queen gets into the
game Pawn to D6 again uh well-known
stuff but uh Knight to D5 is what Magnus
chose Pawn to D6 and pawn to C3 now
preparing to strike in the center and
Morley defends with um there is a game
where H6 was played here he plays Bishop
to E6 and it is now already as of move
eight that we have a completely new game
so okay uh Pawn to D4 Magnus strikes in
the center e captures C captures and now
First bishop captures on D5 uh we have e
captures on D5 if you go after the dark
Square Bishop first then Bishop captures
on B3 attacks the queen so uh it's a
yeah nice little in between move now
Queen captures or a captures doesn't
really matter D captures and it's a
perfectly fine position for black if not
better uh so that why e captures on D5
uh and now we have Bishop to B4 with
check King to F1 and now Knight to E7
getting ready to pick up on D5 uh Queen
to D3 uh and now we have Queen to D7 uh
maybe castling King side maybe castl and
queen side all depends on what Magnus
decides to go for and the Magnus decides
to go for Pawn to H4 uh which means that
Murley will likely not be castling King
side even though King side castles is
perfectly safe uh he decides to Castle
Queen side obviously he wants um uh to
have a more interesting over game
regardless of who his opponent is uh but
he doesn't do it first first H6 and only
now after Pawn to H5 Knight E captures
on D5 and after Rook to H4 Magnus going
for The Rook Li now he castles Queen
side even though again King side castles
is the the safer Choice uh Magnus goes
A3 attacks the bishop here Bishop to A5
and now Pawn to A4 trying to open up um
M's King side to go after the black king
So Bishop to B6 and now Knight to D2 uh
we have Rook H to E8 and now a captures
on B5 a captures and Knight to E4 so
okay a very interesting position here em
has to keep an eye on this B5 Pawn but
he has a fairly strong presence in the
center here the knights are are very
well placed usually you say the knights
aren't very well placed if they are
defending each other but sometimes it it
just works here he plays King to B7 and
Magnus plays Queen to F3 a nice idea
here if you want you could go for Bishop
captures on H6 right away it's very much
doable for example Bishop captures on H6
and after G captures now you play Knight
captures on F6 and after Knight captures
Queen to F3 check nicely connects with
the Knight here and if you can play C6
you can play D5 you could play Knight to
E4 all are all are very much possible
and for example Queen captures Pawn to
D5 uh White takes back the pawn equal
material uh Bishops of opposite color
which isn't really relevant here unless
you trade off the queens and Rooks so
probably the side that gets to attack
will have the the upper hand so this is
one way to play it however after Queen
to be king to B7 Magnus played Queen to
F3 of course he wants to put his Queen
on the same diagonal as the king and now
he has some very tricky ideas now you
know if for example Knight captures on
F6 or if Bishop captures on H6 and
Knight captures on F6 uh you will not be
able to move this Knight due to the pin
on on this diagonal so here M played
Queen to C6 of course not allowing that
and also in some lines maybe you have to
be a little bit careful for The Rook not
to move from the back rank as the queen
is now also putting pressure on the
bishop on C1 H and the Magnus could uh
well there are basically two ways he can
play this he can play Knight back to G3
if he wants to keep the tension and he
could go for Bishop captures on H6 now
uh which is kind of what he played uh
but also Knight captures on F6 and now
you simply trade everything captures you
will go captures on C6 King captures and
Bishop captures on C on F7 uh winning
back the pawn and it's an equal end game
Rook to f8 Bishop to G6 and okay now now
we play the D4 Pawn is a little bit weak
but you know perfectly playable however
Magnus played Bishop captures on H6 now
and uh you have to decide what to do
here it's a very tricky position but
Magnus obviously missed something here
because it's not the same as with the
queen on D7 so feel free to pause the
video and try to find the absolute
strongest way for Murley to continue
this while I give you a couple of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on finding
this idea and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is Rook
captures on e4 this is Believe It or Not
the move that Magnus missed even though
it seems like a fairly obvious t IC uh I
have no idea how he missed it actually
I've started following the game at
around when Magnus played Queen to F3
and here Murley was already down to some
I believe 5 minutes on the clock Magnus
had like half an hour and I believe he
was also playing on his time a little
bit maybe that resulted in him missing
this but now okay what are you going to
do you you just lost material and you
have to take it back okay Rook captures
on e4 G captures on H6 and now what uh
uh maybe he thought that Knight would
capture Rook but no just G captures on
H6 Now The Rook has to move Rook back to
E1 and now King back to B8 unpinning and
now mle has two knights for a rook which
is which is of course quite a lot we
have Rook to E2 and now uh Queen to B7
and now the problem is you can't really
move the Knight the queen on C6 is
undefended and you already moved the the
king from B7 so you don't want to play
King back to B7 so Queen to B7 and now
Bishop captures on D5 just going after
the pawn here now you have to capture
with the Knight otherwise the Knight
just hangs Knight captures and queen
captures on F7 we have Pawn to C6
offering a queen trade and Magnus goes
for it Queen captures King captures and
now uh Rook to D1 you have to defend the
D4 Pawn it's a not not too bad of an
endgame Rook against the bishop and
Knight but with the the D4 pawns being
so weak and you having to defend it with
a full Rook uh not the best maybe King
to C7 and now Rook to E6 going after the
pawn and it seems like okay if Magnus
can actually win the H6 pawn and he can
start those King side pawns um uh being
pushed up the board uh should be very
nice for him but Morley finds a tactic
that defends very nicely Rook to f8 and
now you cannot go after the pawn if you
capture the pawn just Knight to E3 check
and the F Pawn is pinned you're going to
lose a rook here or The Exchange in the
game so here Rook to D2 Magnus needs to
defend but now Rook to F6 and he saves
the H6 Pawn so Rook to E4 by Magnus now
comes King to D7 Pawn to G3 and Rook to
F5 now uh putting pressure on the pawn
Here pawn to G4 defending and Rook to F7
we have Rook Rook to D3 and now Knight
to C7 so okay again if those uh pawns
can uh get pushed uh should be okay if
not probably it's going to be very hard
for Magnus to hold this we have Rook e
to E3 uh and now Knight to E6 uh
guarding the G5 Square not allowing and
also the F4 Square not allowing the the
pawn pushes to continue uh we have Pawn
to D5 sort of a trick if Bishop captures
an E3 play Then you have this nice uh D
captures on E6 fisha where after King
captures you will sort of equalize here
uh as the material is now equal and it's
a rook end game so it will result in the
draw so after D5 C captur on D5 a very
simple solution uh Rook to F3 by Magnus
now Rook to G7 going after the pawn and
The Rook captures on D5 we have Rook
captures on G4 and now Rook to F6 again
Magnus hopes the uh to win the H6 Pawn
but now Bishop to D4 attacking the rook
and what's the real idea uh well after
Rook captures on H6 now Rook to F4 going
after the F2 Pawn so you're basically
shifting one type of Advantage into
another you first you were playing for
material now you're already playing for
the attack you have the bishop and Rook
going after the white king and the
Knight will uh soon join them Rook
captures on
B5 uh Rook captures on F2 with check
this also forces the white king to
remain on the first rank King to E1 and
now Knight to C5 and now once Knight to
D3 lands uh of course you know that's
pretty much it as you know your your
checkmating patterns King to D1 by
Magnus and now Bishop to E3 with Tempo
attacking the rook and it was in this
position on move 45 that Magnus Carlson
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here uh the point is
that after you give a check here or you
don't doesn't really matter you best
move with Tempo black king also moves
with Tempo attacks the rook and that's
it wherever you move the Rook uh once
Knight to D3 lands that's it you control
all of the squares here uh and um uh
Rook to D2 will be Checkmate so there's
no way to stop this you can stop it you
can play Rook to C8 check sorry you
can't go there and then go Rook to C2
sort of stops Checkmate uh but then just
this Knight captures on B2 check and you
either have to give up The Rook or you
know there's really not much you can do
you can you can give up the exchange
with captures captures but again you're
down a full piece and okay you can you
kind have to fight against this P Pawn
but it's very easy you will just play
King C4 King to D3 and Checkmate the
white king and the only way for white to
prevent this is to actually go after the
pawn and try to check you once King
reaches D3 but now we're just going to
give a check and after King E1 pick up
the Free Pawn with this Pawn being
defended white has zero counterplay here
so yeah really a weird game by Magnus
with the white pieces no less uh but uh
yeah uh probably here at this moment
where he played the bishop captures on
H6 is where it all went wrong like I
said it was possible on the previous
move if he went for it without this
queen to F3 move it's uh definitely
possible to play it but with the queen
on C6 a new variation introduced itself
uh and well he fell vict to it uh so
very nicely done by mle kakin always
with a pleasant surprise on this channel
uh let me just check the standings after
the the first seven rounds as two more
rounds will be played so uh on five and
a half points we have a lot of people so
on five and a half points shared first
place Naran javak sarov arjuni David
paravian mle kin nck yakub so those are
the people on five and a half then with
five you have Hikaru param makulu and
katov shimanov vako kaidanov Gregory
kaidanov The Legend 64 years old uh uh
playing amazingly he's number 13 and he
won a very nice game against Jordan P
Forest uh yeah probably the game that
we're going to show next uh so you know
stay tuned for that uh so yeah that's
the game and a little bit of extra info
about the event I hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank your mom's moded
mate tuer bman Edie IND bullet chest
thriller.com and Chad Smith for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World uh so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day